In this problem, a treated effluent is
discharged into a natural stream
resulting in combined flow conditions
characterized by the following data. The
carbonatous BOD5 concentration is 5 mg
per liter. The BOD5 concentration is 7
mg per liter. The ultimate BOD
concentration is 9 mg per liter.
The effluent temperature is
26°. The upstream stream temperature is
19°. The combined flow temperature is
21°. Additionally, the base reeration
rate constant at 21° C is
0.43 days to the
minus1. The base deoxxygenation rate
constant at 21° C is 0.26. 26 days to
the
minus1. The temperature correction
factor for rearration is
1.022 and the temperature correction
factor for de oxygenation is
1.045. The stream velocity is 1.2 ft
pers. Field measurements show that after
3 days of travel time, the dissolved
oxygen concentration reaches a minimum
of 6.4 4 mg per liter. Based on these
conditions, the maximum dissolved oxygen
concentration in milligs per liter in
the stream is most nearly what when
assumed to represent saturation
conditions. So in this problem, we are
being asked to find the
maximum dissolved oxygen concentration
in the stream.
Searching the environmental reference
manual for dissolved oxygen will take us
to a section called stream modeling
specifically to the streeter Phelps
equation. This is given as follows.
D sub C
= K1 over
K2 L
sub0
E raised to the minus K1
*
TC where DC is the maximum dissolved
oxygen deficit in milligs per liter. K1
is the de oxygenation rate constant base
E in days to the minus1. K2 is the
reeration rate constant base E in days
to the
minus1. L sub0 is the initial BOD
ultimate in the mixing zone. And then TC
is the time at which the minimum
dissolved oxygen occurs in days.
Since we have such a long problem
statement, there's a lot to look
through, but we can find that all of our
terms required are already given. So,
let's just start filling them in. We're
going to be solving for D
subC.
K1, our deoxxygenation rate
constant, is going to be 0.26.
K2 our rearration rate constant is going
to be
0.43. L sub0 our initial BOD ultimate in
the mixing zone is going to be 9 mg per
liter. Then we have E to the minus K1 is
0.26 again and our TC here is given as 3
days of travel
time. Once we solve this out we can see
that DC equals
2.49 almost identical to our first
answer in number one. So, this problem
has a long problem statement, but like
many others we've done, it can be solved
very quickly if you simply know what
equation to look for. So, searching for
dissolved oxygen in the reference manual
will bring us to the Strereer Phelps
equation. If we can plug in our terms
from there, all we have to do is solve
the problem. And that's it.